que pasa el tiempo, y no entiendo la maldad del ser humano, aunque sé que es parte inherente
del ser humano.
Siento primero un gran respeto hacia mis padres por lo que pasaron, el hecho de haber sido
destruido ellos como personas, porque aunque se diga que no, que es una experiencia, no
es una experiencia, es una destrucción, fue una parte de su vida, fue una historia, fueron
rotos siglos, porque no se rompen cinco años de vida tan fácil.
Mi mamá, cuando mi madre estaba viva, oír de Polonia, eso era pecado, lo cual yo le
entiendo, porque para ella era humillante, degradante, recordar su vida, y nunca hablaba
de su vida de joven en Polonia.
A la muerte de mi madre decidimos toda la familia ir y recorrer todo lo que ellos pasaron,
y todavía me recuerdo cuando mis cuentos infantiles se convirtieron en verdad, en constatar
dónde estaban ellos escondidos, en donde, cosas que tú no podías creer, habían cosas
que mi padre nunca contó, cuando tratamos de buscar el camino a su vivo, que es una
cosa que él casi nunca la cuenta, y que en ese momento la contó, y cómo me contó que
a mi mamá le cortaron todo el pelo, para mí eso fue traumático, me dio mucha rabia,
me dio impotencia, por ejemplo, el saber que yo nada más tenía niñera, y el encontrarme
con la hija de la niñera de mi mamá, es decir, el haberse me negado por todo lo que
pasó, una historia que yo tenía derecho, a tener familia, a tener ancestro, a tener
una religión, a tener una cultura que no fuera escondida.
Ellos miraron a este país, y puedo decir que jamás he sentido la ofensa de ser budía,
sino más bien he sentido un gran orgullo, pero un orgullo con dolor, y si dijéramos
que atrás del tiempo se ha transformado en rabia, en rabia a lo que pasó, a las consecuencias
que han dejado, que yo he visto, hasta en mi propia familia, personas que han quedado
enfermas, que de eso no se habla, como consecuencia de la guerra.
El ver cómo ha marcado, y cuando se marca, no se marca una sola generación, se marcan
muchas generaciones.
Por eso es importante que esto se siga viviendo, yo felicito a todo esto, y también quisiera
hacerle como un reconocimiento a mi papá, a su fortaleza, que estando en las propiedades
de él, mi hijo trajo de los bosques de él este leño, que cuando desapareció el viaje,
este leño voló por todos lados y yo lo recogí.
Esto es muy simbólico porque yo no tengo ni consulta, y cuando yo en algún momento
flaqueo veo esto, si ellos pudieron, porque yo no, pero es muy duro, ok, es muy duro porque
te daña tu identidad, como hija, como ser humano, y como miembro de la sociedad, porque
aunque mi función en esta vida es ayudar a la gente, pero pasa el tiempo y tengo rabia,
y quiero dar esto a mi papá como recuerdo, pero luego me lo devuelve, porque es mi fortaleza.
El leño es un trozo, ya va, el leño es un trozo de los bosques que perteneció a
su juventud, en donde mismo lo recoge, porque tuvimos la oportunidad de ver todas sus propiedades,
de ver cómo se formó, cómo comenzó su carrera profesional, me parece increíble
ver balanzas de peso donde se pesaba el trigo de 1936 que me provocaba traérmela, porque
uno se necesita historia, uno se necesita raíz, porque los tallos del ser humano se
doblan a través de la vida, pero las raíces no, y eso es lo que nos falta, por lo menos
a esta generación, a los hijos, el producto del holocausto.
La otra hija.
Bueno, yo como, como el yerno, chiquito, y cariñosamente le digo al abuelo, nací en
un pueblo de Venezuela, muy retirado de aquí de la ciudad de Caracas, que se llama San
Cristóbal, muy cerca de Colombia, conocí la familia y nací en el año 42, justamente
cuando estaba en pleno desmán, el holocausto, y no llegaban las noticias, y en mi niñez
todo se me ocultaba, todo se me escondía, y solamente a través del tiempo fue que vine
viendo la realidad de lo que había aprendido acerca de lo que había sucedido en una distancia
de tanto tiempo y de poca información dentro de mi pueblo, y cuando hicimos la visita a
Polonia y a los campos de concentración, fue cuando pude palpar en realidad lo triste,
lo grave, lo duro, lo fuerte y lo inhumano que fue haber estado en esa vida tantos años,
cualquier persona que le hayan privado su libertad, que no sabía su futuro, lo que
había pasado, y me uno a lo que dice Gisela, que aprendimos tanto, y la fortaleza del abuelo
de poder reconocer, pero paso por paso, a esta edad que él tiene, de 84 años de edad,
que nos podía llevar a una esquina y nos decía cualquier detalle mínimo, y todavía
estaba presente ese detalle, inclusive una panadería, y todavía la panadería tenía
el sabor del pan que él nos contaba a nosotros, como él lo disfrutaba, y cuando llegamos
a todas sus tierras, en donde él decía, ábrenme ese galpón, que aquí detrás hay
un apagador donde yo prendía y apagaba la máquina de trigo, y abríamos la puerta,
volteábamos y estaba el apagador todavía intacto. Era una cosa sorprendente la memoria
de él, la vida que él conllevó, y que todavía esa infraestructura está vigente, está activa
en manos de otra persona, al cual le pertenece a él, y nunca ha tomado derecho a que su
propiedad le sea devuelta. Es más, conocimos, como dijo Gisela, la nana, la que cuidaba
a su mamá, o un servicio de su mamá, que todavía existe, y una persona que cuando
reconoció el nombre del abuelo, se pusieron a llorar los dos, alguien que había convivido
junto con él, que lo reconoció cuando se identificaron. Fue una emoción, pero de haber
palpado lo que él nos estaba contando, y poderlo llevar a la vida real, es un cambio
muy diferente. Ahora, ¿cómo fue la vida de ellos? Fue muy dura, y más dura cuando
vimos todas esas cárceles frías, todos esos alambres de púas, y todas esas infraestructuras
que todavía alguna de ellas se conservan, y como dice Gisela, hasta el pelo cuando
lo vimos, podíamos pensar que estaba hasta el pelo de su mamá ahí puesto. Espero que
nunca más se repita una cosa, una barbaridad esta.
Bueno, muchas gracias a toda la familia por estar aquí.